nous sommes le groupe coeur de la
majorité présidentielle qui doit être à
l'origine de la construction de majorité
de projet au sénat je pense que sur les
ordonnances relatives au dialogue social
sur le budget sur la loi de sécurité
intérieure dont nous avons parlé nous
sommes à même d'essayer de porter des
consensus le plus large possible et nous
comprenons que vous allez donc allé voir
les différents groupes politiques qui
composent de senna discuté devant voilà
sur ce texte on peut trouver une
majorité
comment ça va se passer exactement moi
on va essayer il faut toujours essayer
de great un peu des casques bleus du
cndd 2-2 concertée de convaincre nous
sommes le groupe qui se reconnaît dans
la majorité présidentielle et l'action
du gouvernement entièrement mais pour
autant nous sommes là aussi pour
s'ouvrir et pour convaincre sur tel
était le projet de du bienfait des
mesures que nous défendons et donc oui
construire des majorités de projets et
notamment pour réviser les institutions
le sénat doit-il être facteur de blocage
le sénat doit-il être une chambre
d'empêchement d'un puissant tu mens je
ne crois pas que les français souhaitent
que le sénat soit finalement quelque
chose qui cloche là vous êtes en train
de dire que aujourd'hui tel qu'il est
avec cette majorité sénatoriale de
droite
il bloque des institutions non je ne
crois pas je pense que c'est le risque
c'est à dire que nous notre notre
volonté c'est de ces d'éviter cela je ne
crois pas moi je ne prête de mauvaises
solutions intelligentes volume à vos
intentions alors je ne fais de procès
d'intention à personne mais ce que je
pensais dans l'attitude préalable je ne
crois pas que les français souhaitent un
sénat qui soit une chambre qui
bloquerait epide veulent plutôt un sénat
qui co construit vous avez vu le sondage
et lab qui a été réalisé 19 % des
français trouvent que le sénat n'est pas
assez représentatifs
57% des français souhaitent qu'il soit
modernisée mais en même temps les
français dans ce sondage sont attachés
au bicaméralisme donc et ne veulent pas
sa disparition a une à une large
majorité
donc je crois que nous avons là le
chemin pour essayer de régler le sénat
parmi les grands chantiers il ya aussi
la future réforme constitutionnelle mais
pour ça si on passe par le parlement il
faut réunir une majorité des trois
cinquièmes des membres du parlement
sénateurs et députés pour l'instant on
est
c'est pas gagné ça dépendra de la façon
dont le texte est construit et co
élaborés il n'est jamais interdit
d'essayer de convaincre au maximum si
nous pensons que cette réforme est juste
qu'elle est équilibrée
alors il n'y a pas de raison que les
autres groupes ne se retourne pas vers
nous et refusent de travailler il faut
il faut essayer de convaincre moi je
sais que parfois les parties les
organisations politiques se complaisent
dans une forme d opposition et hop je
suis je suis toujours j'ai toujours
porté l'optimisme de la volonté il ya
parfois le pessimisme de la raison mais
il ya toujours l'optimisme de la volonté
qui est là vous êtes 22 aujourd'hui dans
le groupe la république en marche au
sénat demain peut-être combien parce que
vous avez eu des signes d après des
appels du pied
comment je ne sais pas je ne sais pas et
je sais ce que je dis c'est que ce
groupe est un groupe ouvert
c'est un groupe qui a vocation à
accueillir toutes celles et tous ceux
qui se reconnaissent dans l'action de la
majorité présidentielle et qui veulent
transfor transformer le pays je ne vais
pas vous donner de chiffres j'espère que
nous serons le maximum j'entends je
comprends que certains disent on est
d'accord avec ça mais pas d'accord avec
tout ça dépend des moments
je pense moi dans la vie politique il
faut plutôt essayer de faire preuve de
clarté sa pensée c'est ma il faut éviter
les confusions ensuite chacun est libre
c'est le rôle d'une assemblée comme le
sénat 2d videmment organiser les débats
dans la plus grande liberté